all right it is now time for another
live reading from my 2011
book
reason fulfilled by revelation the
christian philosophy debates in france
and we have finished the long
almost 100 pages long historical
introduction and we are going to today
dive into the first of the translated
documents um titled is there a christian
philosophy by emil brahier who is a
fairly young scholar
at the time kind of a young turk as we
often call people like that some people
might have called him a young punk but
he had already established himself as a
historian of philosophy
this was published in the
review de mediphysique de la morale
in 1931
in the uh volume
38 number two so that would place it in
the summer
and um
it's it's kind of a longish piece it is
pages 99
through
127
so
may take me the entire hour to read it
we'll see
and it's quite an interesting
piece um hopefully we'll have time for q
a afterwards
so i'm going just to
start in on this
and it's divided into
uh i believe yeah six sections and each
has to do with or no sorry five sections
each has to do with a
particular
era of philosophy
so
no further ado
in a note in his the christian
philosophy of saint augustine monsieur
gilson says that it would be appropriate
to submit the concept of christian
philosophy to re-examination
in matters of the history of ideas
questions are in actuality often more
difficult to set out than they are to
resolve once they are set out we have to
deal not only with defined entities but
with human thoughts that struggle for in
in equilibrium ceaselessly compromised
by the research itself
fixed concepts are at the end of history
within an imaginary horizon they are not
at the beginning like completely
finished things just waiting for a
thought that examines them in order to
declare itself in agreement or
disagreement
let us refrain then from first defining
philosophy and christianity in order to
seek out
using these concepts as a framework
whether there is a christian philosophy
we would run too much risk of finding in
our conclusions only what our prejudices
would have put into our definitions
perhaps then one will say that the
difficulty here is more normative
than factual
if it is just a matter of christian
philosophy's existence
will not historical experience provide
us with a sufficient answer
by showing us the existence of doctrines
that claim that title but we shall reply
these doctrines must still justify the
title and that is a matter for the
historian's judgment the history of
philosophy cannot be a passive simple
notation of facts one of its most
important functions is to investigate
what the doctrines it studies really are
and if they are always what they profess
to be
the historian
must discover underneath their apparent
and social existence the thoughts that
produce them or more simply ask how they
justify their existence
the question of christian philosophy the
question of the existence of christian
philosophy cannot be a pure question of
fact
but in this case is there not a
circumstance that deprives history of
any right to judge by its ordinary
method indeed who can say what is
christian and what is not who can lay
down the law if not a magisterium that
doubtless takes different forms
according to the variety of christian
confessions but that alone has the power
to define orthodoxy
in any case this authority that admits
or excludes matters very little here it
assumes in advance actually that
christian philosophy is possible
because it finds itself
ready to receive as well as to condemn
it matters little to us what more or
less ephemeral value ecclesiastical
politics is conferred on this or that
system our question is broader
we are asking what christianity's
intellectual vocation is what its
positive part is in the development of
philosophical thought so section one
western thought was formed in a
christian land that is a fact but that
christianity spread out within regions
that were impregnated by greek culture
and that had never known any other
culture is another fact during all the
middle ages matters of the intellect had
belonged solely to the clergy and the
monastic orders that is true but it is
no less true that intellectual
civilization has transformed itself
since the 16th century once initiative
ceased to come from the clergy so much
that on a first view it is not evident
that christianity played an important
role
from the start there was we know the
feeling of a great disagreement between
the hellenic tradition of philosophy and
the new beliefs for the helene the true
object of philosophy was to discover
order or the cosmos each being and
principally the directive forces of
nature souls and god must be defined by
the exact and navarrariter place that it
occupies in this eternal order we must
also notice the sort of intellectual
scandal that christianity produced once
pagan philosophers came to know it
starting from the second century of our
era and the impression they felt of its
genuine absurdity
what could it be for them this worldless
god who throughout an attorney remains
inactive and then all of a sudden sets
himself to create according to his will
what is the pretended goodness of god
who waits centuries to manifest himself
by redemption who changes nature in
order to incarnate himself who
transforms the order he has established
there is a nearly indignant toned in all
of these interrogations which are
repeated without a break from celsius's
true discourse in the second century of
our era until the last of the pagan
neoplatonists
on their side the christians did not
feel the disagreement any less
the affirmation of the eternity of the
world in particular the affirmation of
an immovable order that perfectly
satisfied reason and the taste for
beauty shocked them as a heresy the
hellenic heresy part excellence which
refuses to admit in things a genuine
history and unpredictable initiatives
such as creation sin and redemption
will christianity then in these
conditions create for itself its own
philosophy be an initiator of a new
intellectual movement in the first
centuries of our era we do not see
anything like that
to the contrary christians like justin
the apologist like origen like saint
gregory of nazianis or saint gregory of
nisa like saint augustine annex
everything they can from pagan
philosophy to christianity
where have we seen where could one see
the fathers having been authors of a new
intellectual culture different from that
which pagan antiquity had transmitted to
them
there is first of all an entire part of
that culture that was neither altered
nor touched by christianity and that is
the part that consists of the sciences
preliminary to philosophy
what during the middle ages were called
the seven arts grammar rhetoric
dialectic arithmetic geometry music and
astronomy
they preserved not only in saint
augustine's works but throughout the
middle ages the habits of mind created
by the helenes that spirit of exactitude
which cannot satisfy itself except by
using well-defined and well-articulated
concepts or a precise calculus
but above all it is the last two of
these sciences mathematics and astronomy
which from the 16th century on regaining
the level greek antiquity it brought
them to and starting the course of
progress again with galileo and
descartes
transformed the conception of the
universe and of man
zeno augustine who transmitted the
traditional scientific culture of his
time without changing anything in it has
he at least transformed the pagan greek
philosophy
into a christian philosophy
no more than his predecessors
and just as he learned greek science and
the books of the orators and the
sophists he later learned philosophy in
the books of platinus and the
neoplatonus it is this purely pagan
philosophy that he transmits to
posterity particularly to the first
centuries of the middle ages for which
he was one of the great authorities but
also in the 17th century when all of the
great systems particularly of descartes
and mal brash were penetrated by the
augustinian spirit
beginning with saint augustine
there is then a very important tradition
that we could believe to be that of
christian philosophy if we did not note
that this claimed christian philosophy
is borrowed entirely from platinus and
plato
but if saint augustine no more than any
of the fathers did not truly create a
philosophy a new conception of the
universe
how being a christian was he able to
integrate with his thought a philosophy
that by its spirit we have seen is not
only foreign but completely opposed to
the dogmas of the catholic religion
it is known that at the time when saint
augustine became acquainted with the
neoplatonic books and latin translations
in particular marius victor's
translations of platinuses and naods a
little before 387 towards the age of 32
he was not yet converted to christianity
but he was soon to be
until then his mind was little oriented
in philosophy's direction
the rhetoricians profession he carried
out corresponded to a purely formal
education having no other goal than the
art of speaking well uninterested in
ideas in a deep way and education quite
widespread as antiquity in antiquity as
it came to its end
on the other side his adherence to the
manichaean sect would soon have turned
him away from philosophy as with
numerous religious acts of that epoch
they were more occupied with rights and
ceremonies than with speculation on the
universe
it is in these conditions that in 387
the intellectual and moral crisis took
place that ended in his conversion to
christianity therefore augustine was
moved and fascinated by platonic
philosophy during the same period that
he sensed the truth of the gospel it is
from the very year of his conversion to
christianity that certain of his
philosophical treatises date such as
contra academicos de bayatavita de
ordinai and soliloquies where he shows
himself the faithful imitator of
platinus and where we discover entire
passages from the ineods in a word
his conversion to platonism did not
appear to him at that moment from an
intellectual point of view something
different from his conversion to
christianity
in the anaeads he finds the same basis
of spirituality as in the gospels and he
attaches himself with the same passion
to both
the very mystery he saw in the anands
the depth of wisdom that he admitted not
yet having penetrated
all this gives a truly religious accent
to what he said about platinus's work
thus saint augustine should have had for
a longer shorter period of time the
illusion that the true philosophy was
not something different from the
christian
religion what is no less certain is that
this illusion did not persist little by
little once the primitive
passion gave way to more reflection we
see him become conscious of the
divergences separating platonism from
dogma and perceive their deep
incompatibility
toward the end of his life
72 years old when he was revising his
own treatises he wrote musing about the
time when he discovered platinus
the praise i made of plato and the
platonus displeases me and not without
reason all
above all because christian doctrine has
to be defended against great errors on
their part
in the interval
uh 40 years separating these two dates
we glimpse augustine's mistrust towards
greek philosophy grow little by little
but not at all in order to replace it by
another philosophy that would be quote
the christian philosophy
it is in a famous passage of the
confessions that he clearly shows his
attitude with respect to platonism
and therein i read not indeed in the
same words but to the same effect
enforced by many and diverse reasons
that quote in the beginning was the word
and the word was with god and the word
was god the same was in the beginning
with god all things were made by him and
without him was not anything that was
made
that which was made by him is quote life
and the life was the light of men
and that the soul of man although it
bears witness to the light yet itself is
not that light but the word of god being
god is that true light that lighteth
every man that cometh into the world
in like manner i read there that the
word of god was born not of flesh nor of
blood nor of the will of man nor the
will of flesh but of god
but that the word was made flesh and
dwelt among us i read not there but that
he emptied himself and took upon him the
form of a servant and was made in the
likeness of men he humbled himself and
became obedient to death even the death
of the cross whereupon god also hath
greatly exalted him from the dead and
have given him a name which is above all
names
those books have not
for that before all times and above all
times thy only begotten son remained
unchangeably co-eternal with thee and
that of his his fullness souls receive
that they may be blessed and by
participation in the wisdom remaining in
him herself
them they are renewed that they may be
wise is there
but
that in due time christ died for the
ungodly and that thou sparest not your
only son but delivered him up for us all
is not there
because thou hast hid those things from
the wise and the prudent and hast
revealed them to babes
because that when they knew god they
glorified him not as god neither were
thankful but became vain in their
imaginations professing themselves to be
wise they became fools
it is difficult to find a page richer
more significative and more full of
meaning for the question with which we
are concerned saint augustine is
condensed into a single dogma all the
content of philosophy this dogma is the
one of an eternal and a movable logos or
word by whose intermediation all things
were made and thanks to whom the human
soul knows them in their immovable order
he condenses on the other hand the
entire christian religion
into a dogma the dogma of the incarnate
word who made himself man in order to
save man
on both sides it is a matter of the word
of the logos
on both sides the defining formulas
whether the eternal word who remains
with god is an instrument of his
creation
or the word incarnated from men are
borrowed from the prologue to the fourth
gospel as if saint augustine wanted
first to indicate that the two
conceptions of the word are equally
christian but that is not the case
however for if we continue reading the
confessions we will soon perceive that
for him this intelligence of the eternal
word acquired by philosophy is worth
nothing in the true religious life which
is the quest for salvation
quote but having read having then read
those books of the plaintiffs and being
admonished by them to seek for
incorporeal truth i saw thy invisible
things understood by the things that are
made assured that thou worked and
weren't infinite and yet not diffused in
space finite or infinite all these
things was i indeed assured
yet too weak to enjoy thee i c i cl
chattered as one while skilled but i had
not sought thy way in christ our savior
i would have proved not skillful but
ready to perish
for now filled with my punishment i had
begun to desire to seem wise yet i
mourned
yet mourned i not but rather was puffed
up with knowledge
he wanted thus to mark the distance the
very abyss between an autonomous
philosophical knowledge
certain of itself but on its own
completely useless and even harmful to
salvation
and the religious life completely
independent of the intellectual life
as for philosophy itself it is not
presupposed by religion any more than it
presupposes religion but it is at least
compatible with christianity
that is what we might at first be able
to believe while reading that single
passage of the confession but let us
look more closely so you know augustine
we say
has condensed the pagan philosophy
completely into the doctrine of the
eternal word this expression seems at
first to suggest a doctrine that is not
only hostile to christianity
but not only is not hostile to
christianity but even has a christian
ring to it since it comes from the
prologue to the fourth gospel in reality
that is not the case
the word that saint augustine speaks
here
speaks of here designates the logos for
reason that the stoics made the cause of
the connective matrix between things in
the world or even the noose or
intelligence whose eternal thoughts
constituted according to the plaintiffs
the intelligible world of which the
sensible world was an imitation to
explain it even more simply let us
recall that the goal of greek philosophy
was to investigate the rational
consequently immovable and fixed order
that is in things
the universal logos or intelligence is
only the metaphysical realization the
projection of this need it is set up
within the ideal the very order that the
sensible world realizes more or less
imperfectly
but the doctrine of the eternal word so
understood has corollaries that are
clearly incompatible with christian
faith namely the eternity of the order
that translates itself in the
imagination by the affirmation of the
eternity of the world
and the eternity of souls since souls
are only particular aspects of the
universal logos
and they collaborate in the order of the
world
thus the theory of the eternal word or
if you like of the rational order of
things grasped in its fullness with all
of its consequences is incompatible with
christian faith so much that we end up
in this veritable incoherence saint
augustine is led to reject as false
because contrary to the faith
consequences of a philosophy whose
principle he nevertheless admits
when the eternity of souls is the matter
under discussion he sets into play
against it the revelation
that teaches us that god has created the
soul why he asks
not rather believe god in matters that
escape the human mind's inquiries and as
to the eternity of the world he requires
us to choose between this doctrine and
the supernatural end religion proposes
we know indeed that the eternity of the
world was imagined by the thinkers of
greece under the form of an indefinite
series of cycles or great years that
would repeat themselves whence this
reflection of saint augustine quote how
is it true beatitude
in the eternity one cannot believe in if
there is always a return of the same
miseries and in any case christ died
only once
consequently
there is not at all in saint augustine's
works a christian philosophy that is to
say a conception of the universe grafted
onto dogma
the only philosophy that he might know
the only one we might find in his works
is the philosophy of plato and platinus
saint augustine did not know any other
intellectual culture than the pagan and
human culture one might say and he does
not ask christian belief for it for a
moment he was able to have the thought
that plato's spirituality coincided with
christ's teaching but he did not hang on
to it
and philosophy remains in his work like
a foreign body its existence always
threatened
all right
next section section two
of the meal breakers is their christian
philosophy
down the length of centuries up into the
beginning of the 13th century the
western middle ages knew the
predominance of augustinianism that is
that mixture of attraction and repulsion
for philosophy that brings it about that
sometimes philosophy is considered to be
a sort of illumination entirely akin to
religion
sometimes to the contrary viewed as an
enemy
but in the 13th century
an attempt had a synthesis between
philosophy and christianity was produced
a completely new one this is the one
thomas authored it is no longer a matter
of gathering philosophy and religion
together as saint augustine believed
possible
saint thomas considers philosophy a
distinct and autonomous science
proceeding from purely rational
arguments without borrowing anything
from revelation
but still more he tries to demonstrate
how and why this philosophy is not and
cannot be opposed at all to christian
revelation thus how this incompatibility
we believe to have found between the
hellenic mind and the religion of
salvation does not exist how philosophy
purely rational can and must become the
intellectual aspect of christian culture
philosophy in saint thomas's works is
not at all a part of religion it is the
work of human reason and it does not
give itself as collaborating and
salvation in any determinant way
but on the other hand it is no longer a
weapon against christianity it enters
like an integrating element into the
christian life which is no less
intellectual than religious and in
conformity to the 13th century's
universalist tendencies saint thomas
strives especially to restore the unity
of culture under the sign of the cross
beginning with the end of the 12th
century and at the beginning of the 13th
the totality of aristotle's works came
to be known in the west
it is difficult to form a picture of the
intellectual agitation caused by the
revelation of a genius who is so
fundamentally foreign to christianity
and who in whose works the specific
traits of the hellenic mind manifested
their depth in a way different than
in what remained of platonism
of those who had been up till then the
great directors of western thought saint
augustine and boethius the first had
been almost completely unaware of
aristotle's work and the second had made
known only a few logical treatises
providing nothing of the comprehensive
view of the universe and of man
contained in aristotle's system
platonism in the form that had
infiltrated through the church fathers
most of the time anonymous and mutilated
reduced to the minuscule portion that
could be reconciled more or less easily
with christian theology
presented itself not as a system but a
more or less vague spiritualism on the
contrary aristotelianism forms a whole
with its systematic assemblage of
well-connected theorems bearing on all
realities from god to matter this is the
first time that western christianity
finds itself face to face with no
intermediary with a production of the
hellenic genius
and how much in order to truly
understand it habits of thought had to
be altered
and in a way the mind center of gravity
displaced
i am thinking here not only of the
heterodox doctrines when naturally fines
in aristotle's work the eternity of the
world opposed to creation and time the
soul existing only as the principle of
the body's life
i am thinking above all of the tonality
of the totality that marks in his works
preoccupations diverging so much
from those of christianity up to then
all platonism actually and this is what
in it had seduced saint augustine was
oriented towards theology and the world
of eternal and intelligible beings
inversely all of aristotle's system is
oriented towards the explanation of
sensible things
god barely appears there as the eternal
mover of the heavens
in aristotle's work the proper object of
philosophy is the nature of the heavens
the elements minerals animals man
considered in his earthly conduct
insofar
as citizen or scholar man's intellectual
knowledge is itself completely engaged
in the sensible nothing in it nothing is
in the understanding that has not been
in sense intellect is not therefore an
intuitive vision of stable and permanent
realities it operates by abstractions
that separate in the sensible data the
common elements that form the genera and
the species there is nothing there for
in human nature such as it is described
in aristotle's works that makes one
presage even from afar the supernatural
drama in which the soul is engaged and
which alone gives christian life meaning
one cannot dream up a deviation more
complete than that which was imposed on
christian thinkers by meditation on
aristotle's works one can insist as much
as one likes that aristotle's para
parapatheticism is currently tied to
christian scholasticism by an
indissoluble bond but it was not always
so and in the 13th century this
conviction went against all traditions
and against the most enlivened
inclinations what was in fact the
attitude at first of the spiritual
powers faced with these new forces
coming from a far off
chris pre-christian past an attitude of
defiance
bans against reading and teaching
aristotle's philosophy were multiplied
in 1215 at the same time that pope
innocent iii founded the university of
paris and gave it its statutes he
enjoined the masters not to read the
metaphysics or the physics and permitted
them the logical treaty sees
his successor gregory ix was no less
obliged to give ground at least
partially before he permitted an
expergiated aristotle in which
everything that could be contrary to
dogma had been effaced
we see the real worries of the powers
who had as their mission safeguarding
catholicism's unity but saint thomas
used a completely different means than
the popes and the councils to vanish
aristotle he did not fight him he did
not critique him
he adopted him
the principle
saint thomas started from is extremely
simple it is this truth cannot be
contrary to truth an obvious principle
since it returns in some to the
principle of non-contradiction actually
if a truth were contrary to a truth one
would have to say that a single and same
thing could be at the same time true and
false
what is important is not the principle
but the way in which it will be applied
the application saint thomas wants to
draw from it concerns the truths
revealed by religion and the truths
discovered by philosophy revealed truth
cannot be contrary to philosophical
truth nor philosophical truth to the
truth of faith
logic does not ask that these truths
elicit or demand each other as augustine
who reconciled philosophical
illumination with the faith of the
christian had sometimes thought
it asks only that they do not destroy
each other
but let us suppose that in fact faith
supplies us with propositions contrary
to those that philosophy admits this is
not a gratuitous supposition
for contrarities of this type abound in
particular cases aristotle's philosophy
does indeed deny things that faith
affirms for example faith tells us the
world was created in time aristotle
tells us the world is uncreated and
exists from all eternity
in order to apply our principle here we
must know which of these two
propositions we will hold as true for a
christian the solution is clear it's
faith that speaks the truth but if a
truth of reason cannot be contrary to a
truth of faith it follows that
aristotle's thesis is only in appearance
a truth of reason in these cases
either aristotle reasoned badly or he
approached a question
that
reason was completely powerless to
resolve
but if faith is thus the measure of
truth how can we still talk about the
autonomy of reason saint thomas's goal
is to show the convergence of the two
great movements that dominate the
spiritual history of our west greek
rationalism represented by aristotle and
christian faith
one can speak of convergence only if
each of these two movements has its own
initiative
its own internal development
but reason no longer possesses its own
initiative once the results of its own
activity are judged by a criterion that
is foreign to it by faith atomist will
respond perhaps that faith does not
alter but on the contrary strengthens
reason for it has a purely negative role
that of excluding certain propositions
that are incompatible with it and it
does not intervene at all in the
positive labor that establishes them so
much that faced with the exclusiveness
of faith which attacks certain
propositions philosophy believed itself
to have demonstrated
reason is led to examine itself and to
become conscious of its own powers and
its own limits
tomism thus presents us with this
surprising paradox of maintaining
together the old medieval formula
philosophia anchila teologiae and the
hellenic formula of the autonomy of
reason
faith exercises that censorship over
philosophy
but does not provide any positive
assistance any impetus such is the sense
in which tomism is a christian
philosophy not at all that christianity
would have contributed any positive
element to our image of the universe
since it borrows this image from a greek
thinker
but that philosophy is certain not to
deviate from the straight line thanks to
the censorship faith exercises over it
this is the only way in which a
philosophy whose preconceptions were not
uniquely and purely theological could
develop within the interior of
christianity
for this censorship to be able to
fulfill its role and so to give birth to
a christian philosophy two conditions
are needed conditions whose possible
fulfillment
saint thomas's contemporaries denied
the first is that one could say with
exactitude from among the philosophical
propositions which ones are contrary to
the faith the second is that reason once
considered as autonomous and spontaneous
could accept a control that does not
come from itself
let us consider the first difficulty
we know that many of aristotle's
philosophical propositions accepted by
saint thomas were condemned by
ecclesiastical authority notably by the
bishop of paris tempier in 1277. let us
consider two of them which are
particularly instructive
the first is the impossibility of
plurality of worlds aristotle had
demonstrated in the dai kylo that it is
impossible there be more than one single
world and he had based his demonstration
on the nature of the elements saint
thomas by accepting this demonstration
was wrong to limit the infinite power of
god
the second is the thesis called that of
the individuation by matter according to
aristotle what distinguishes one man
from another peter from paul is not
their essence which is the same in both
of them but as an entire ensemble of
accidents due to the conditions of time
and of place in which the specif
specific form had to be produced one
individual is therefore not
fundamentally distinct from another
except by accidents depending on
fleeting circumstances
but for a christian accepting such a
view such a way of viewing things as a
serious matter for the immortal subject
of a supernatural destiny taught by
christianity is the permanent individual
aristotle's thesis the risks confusing
individuals in the species still be
these two theses whose orthodoxy st
thomas's
adversary suspected saint thomas himself
considered as perfectly reconcilable
with orthodoxy which proves at least
that the criterion of faith censorship
is far from being something clear and
easily applicable
we have a decisive proof of this in a
famous discussion that saint thomas
undertook on the subject of the eternity
of the world his this thesis is closely
connected with the hellenic mind and in
particular with parapatheticism even
more it was supposed by the first and
most important of the arguments that
prove god's existence
this is the famous argument known as the
argument from the first mover god is
only actually proven as the mover of the
heavens and if in its turn the movement
of the heavens is not eternal their
mover would become entirely useless
saint thomas who attaches an extreme
importance to that proof who sees in it
actually the soul means by which human
reason bound up in the sensible world
can arrive at the borders of theology
and can know god as one knows a cause
from its effect does not conceal that
there is a serious objection here
two reasons he says seem to weaken this
proof the first is that it proceeds from
the supposition of the eternity of the
world that among catholics is supposed
to be false
still and this is what is most
astonishing to his contemporaries he
does not consider that the aristotelian
thesis of the eternity of the world
is precisely the contrary
of the christian thesis of creation and
he deploys the greatest subtlety to
establish there's no disagreement
between the two of them the word
creation he tells us in substance
signifies a certain connection of
causality a creative cause is that which
produces from nothing a being with all
of its attributes then he continues this
definition does not contain anything
that implies that this cause began to
act at a certain moment in time we can
set back the beginning of the action of
this cause as far back as we like
without ceasing to conceive of it as
creative in particular we can set it
back to infinity and say that it never
started to act because it had been
eternally an action
from this point on it's possible to
conceive an eternal world that was still
however created by this reason that it
was created since eternity
it is not certain that this claimed
agreement does not conceal a very deep
disagreement
saint thomas with his attempt at
reconciliation ends up doing wrong to
both aristotle and the bible let's
examine the principle of argumentation
by which aristotle and the physics
demonstrates the eternity of the world
this argument is founded on the nature
of time time taken in itself is
continuous that is it is such that no
present moment could be the current
limit of a time that is passed there
cannot be a moment that would be the
first
then the argument continues time is the
measure of movement it cannot exist
without there also existing irregular
and periodic movement that it would have
to measure
this movement is the movement of the
heavens from which derives the division
of time into period the movement of the
heavens has not had a beginning and the
world is eternal what matters to us the
most is less the content of the proof
than the way of proving it is the very
type of way peculiar to a helene
the proof is based on the consideration
of the fixed nature or essence of things
it is the nature of the world to be
eternal because time which has not had a
beginning cannot exist without it let us
consider to the contrary the way in
which the matter is presented in
thomas's work if the world is eternal it
would be because it would have pleased
god to create it from eternity if it was
created in time it's because it pleased
god to do that the eternity of the world
if it existed would not therefore flow
from its nature but from a will of god
which is for us purely arbitrary which
belongs only to history and which we
cannot know except by revelation
there is a complete antithesis
between hellenic reason proceeding from
clear and defined concepts and christian
dogma the divine comedy where one sees
only persons acting in a supernatural
and unpredictable
manner
these examples will suffice perhaps
to show how far the use of this
censorship of philosophy of faith was
indecisive in precise arbitrary this
censorship that saint thomas wished to
use to determine what in philosophy was
both rational and acceptable to a
christian
but supposing this starting point
possible
we encounter a difficulty that is not
the smallest one
we all know that tomism wants itself
above all on respecting the autonomy of
reason it's no less true that reason
needs some sort of religious tutelage
since in the last resort faith is called
in to exclude from philosophy theses
that are contrary to faith human reason
cannot be completely certain of the
value of its own demonstrations
for theses that faith reject are the
theses it is believed to have
demonstrated
once faith speaks philosophy is so to
speak required to seek out in what it
claimed as demonstration some sophism or
paralogism hidden up to then
consequently tomism always supposes that
reason is incapable of finding in itself
its own measure and its own rule
here then is a conception of reason very
narrowly tied to the tomest idea of a
christian philosophy human reason has
according to st thomas two
interdependent aspects it is not
intuitive that is to say it does not
directly know the essence of things
it is limited to the domain of general
ideas that it abstracts from sensible
things
consequently we cannot have the illusion
of knowing the real nature of anything
moreover reason discusses and argues
much more than it demonstrates it is
made less to discover truths than to
judge whether the proposed theses are
true or false
the single method of philosophy is to
set out systematically following each
theses
the arguments pro and contra and to show
through a discussion which ones are the
most decisive
two aspects we can we say that are
interdependent for it is in fact because
the mind can never attain adequate
conceptions of the reality of things
which does not suppose less than the
participation in the knowledge of the
essence of things such as they are in
the divine understanding that the
philosopher can grasp only fragments and
limited aspects of things which forces
him into
endless discussions in tomism human
reason is thus entirely infirm and
feeble both by its field of exploration
which renders it dependent on the senses
and by the incomplete and imperfect way
by which it penetrates them in the
series of created intellects it is at
the lowest degree well below angelic
intellects
this assessment of human reason
is a completely necessary element in the
economy of doctrine it is this type of
congenital weakness that takes from from
it all its weapons for resisting faith
admonishments we have in this a
particularly clear example in the way
saint thomas rejects his contrary to the
faith one of the most well-known
aristotelian theses that of the identity
of all human intellects
the principle of this thesis is the
following in intellectual knowing the
knowing subject becomes completely
identical to the known object to the
degree that we know things
scientifically all that is individual in
our knowing is erased and at the limit
in scientific contemplation there is
nothing more in our mind than the object
we know
all trace of individuality has
disappeared
and since the objects of science are the
same for all intellects when a geometer
is attained the knowledge of the sphere
the intelligible sphere that he
contemplates and whose properties he
sees does not differ in any way from the
sphere that another geometer who has
attained the same knowledge contemplates
but if intellects are identical to their
objects and if the objects are
themselves identical among themselves
it follows that all intellects are
identical
since the period prior to saint thomas
this thesis had appeared worrisome to
christian faith in fact this faith
supposes that each individual taken
separately has a supernatural destiny
that belongs particularly to him that
each reasonable being merits election or
incurs damnation
aristotle's thesis no longer allows
distinguishing human beings from each
other by what makes them be
human beings by their reason but instead
only by faculties they have in common
with animals and by which they cannot
possess merit or demerit saint thomas
like all the christian peripatetics
therefore rejects this thesis he rejects
it by applying his ordinary criterion
disagreement with faith
but in the name of the principle no
truth is contrary to a truth he had to
be able to demonstrate that the thesis
is also in disagreement with reason
but it is not at all in disagreement and
thomas was obliged to admit that this
thesis as aristotle presented it flows
from the nature of intellect
but he says
even if the intellect of all was unique
because it did not contain the natural
cause of multiplication it would still
be possible to admit multiplication
without contradiction and virtue of a
supernatural cause
this passage tells us with all the
clarity one could desire that the
multiplicity of intellects is a miracle
that contradicts the intellect's own
nature
the weakness of reason is therefore such
that even though it exercises itself in
a perfectly correct manner as it does in
the present case by deducing the unity
of intellect from its nature
it will never be sure of the validity of
its conclusions
it is therefore clear that in these
conditions in order to arrive at making
the talmus philosophy a christian
philosophy
one must think that it possesses no
conclusion offering us the least
security before having been confronted
by faith
the christian must always take into
account the supernatural that can render
all natural laws merely accidental
the arbitrariness of an all-powerful
will
that inserts itself at its whim into the
tissue of things opposes itself to
hellenism's rational and immovable order
finally we find at the end of this
account something almost the contrary of
what seemed to have been promised us at
the start in place of the autonomy of
reason that takes the initiative of
philosophical thought the heteronomy of
a reason completely incapable of
directing itself and knowing the scope
of its own conclusions
this would be at least tomism's logical
conclusion
inevitably it was necessary to choose
between these two positions
either submit reason to faith to the
point that every systematic and reasoned
arrangement of notions becomes
completely useless since the fact of
entering into a system of being deduced
is not at all the justification of a
truth of an affirmation or even a
presumption of its favor
or
admit reasons initiative and the
possibility of reason being its own
judge but tomism did not wish to take
either side and it remains always
hesitant and timid between them
he claims to be properly rationalist and
intellectualist and there isn't a
positive and realist spirit a desire to
treat philosophical problems without
making any transit transcendent
illumination that places us directly in
contact with god intervene
as do the augustinians but on the other
hand
there is also a complete insecurity in
what bears on the results of its inquiry
and a near absolute impossibility of
establishing a systematic and coherent
philosophy
so it's been about 45 minutes of reading
and we've managed to get to page 116
there are still
three shorter sections
and roughly
11 pages to go so i think i'm going to
end the reading
here but i'm happy to
take questions comments for about the
next 15 minutes
before we round out the hour
hello to ricky and mark and everybody
else who's here so what we've seen is is
uh bray here is saying
if we want to figure out whether there
really is christian philosophy we need
to look at the contenders
and he begins by looking at augustine as
being sort of like the paradigmatic
patristic figure that is the among the
church fathers and then he jumps all the
way to the 13th century and examines uh
the reception of aristotelianism
and saint thomas aquinas
as we're going to see people pointing
out
in subsequent parts
his history is actually
not
as great as he pretends it to be
he's kind of misinterpreting augustine
and um
the church fathers it's a little bit
debatable about the
thomas stuff i mean i i kind of think
that some of his stuff is perhaps a bit
more on point um
than
the dismissals of him by the thomas jill
some maritime
you know van steinbergen sertian some of
the other people dismissing him have
have done i will say this though um when
they had the actual debate in the
society frances de philosophy joseon
basically played socrates to
brahes pick whatever figure who's
getting his his butt handed to him by
socrates um
bray here basically
contradicted himself showed that he he
was wrong about and didn't understand
quite a bit about um the history that he
was he was talking about which did not
look good for him unfortunately the
society france says the philosophy
allows only the translations of the
presentation by joseon and the appended
letter by by blondel not the actual
debate
between um joseon and bragiaire not
maura 10's presentation which shows up
basically in his essay on christian
philosophy and not the
back and forth between
uh jill song and brunchfig but what are
you gonna do
all right
so this is an interesting question by by
mark in terms of the epistemological
relation between faith and reason how
would you say the will fits in in a
christian context so we have to we have
to know what we mean by the will and i
would say that
the will is not something
to begin with the will as a reality is
not something simple
and for the other part the will is
understood differently by different
thinkers so the will is understood by
augustine
is not precisely the same thing although
it covers a lot of the same ground as
the will understood by saint thomas
or by anselm or boethius
there's there's interconnections but
they're not exactly the same and we
could extend this further the descartes
hobbs clearly very different conceptions
of
of will there
um i think that this is this is a really
interesting point
in these christian philosophy debates
you could say that they were much more
oriented
towards thinking out these matters
with a focus on what you can call
theoretical or speculative philosophy
you know metaphysics epistemology
and there was
less of a coherent focus i don't want to
say there was no focus but less of a
coherent focus on practical philosophy
on ethics on
even aesthetics or
other things and
jill so discusses some of these things
in his um
spirit of medieval philosophy which is
another major contribution to the to the
debates and obviously blondel
is going to highlight the will
but most of the other interlocutors
really didn't
um i mean you see discussion of will
here in brazier's stuff
but it's not the human will that's being
talked about right it's the divine will
and what is the relation between the
human and the divine will
at best analogous if not completely
equivocal
um
so
i don't know if that really answers the
question um but
i'll say that at least in these debates
there was not as much discussion as we
probably would have liked
of the nature of the will now later on
um some thinkers who are approaching
these topics
will indeed talk a good bit about the
will and i have in mind somebody like
dietrich von hildenbrand right who
is too young to participate in these
debates
he's a student of mock shalers and he
will go on and become a very important
catholic phenomenologist in the 20th
century and he participates in some
discussion about christian philosophy
later on i actually have a paper that i
i don't think i ever did publish on
dietrich von hilton brand and christian
philosophy and these these debates and
how to understand his position and he he
devotes a lot of attention to the will
and to the heart
had mock shaler
been around long enough to
to
involve himself and he might have might
well have um he probably would have had
something interesting to say
so
all right uh ricky says is giordano
bruno mentioned no not really much i
mean he's a marginal figure really in
the history of philosophy
so
yeah
mark says is faith a matter of will or
to use greek faculties or logos it's not
it's not really
just one of any of those sort of things
and again we have to be careful when we
talk about noose or logos
they are not the same thing
for
for greek thinkers i mean the
um the noose of the uh
of aristotle is not always the same
thing even in aristotle i wouldn't i'd
be careful like translating noose in
nico mccann ethics book six as the same
thing as noose in in some other places
sometimes he's being loosey-goosey with
it it's not the same thing as when a
stoic uses noose or logos it's not the
same thing as when a neoplatonist uses
it
faith
can be understood in a number of
different ways it can be understood in
terms of belief it can be understood in
terms of action it can be understood as
a virtue
and not these are you know analogously
related to each other
um
mark asks i mean did the christian
thinkers drawing on the greeks ever
offer interpretations of where faith
fits in many yeah i mean the church
fathers are
are full of this but they don't just
talk about faith they also talk a lot
about
love you know karis or
[Music]
faith is not something that exists on
its own
like
you know a product that you can
pick up or
look use an example a mask you can put
on you know
as a matter of fact
those metaphorical things
that are in paul's letters about you
know put on the breastplate of this and
the helmet of this i think that's
those
christians you know
read those and then they get themselves
all
bollocksed up because they think that
the there is something like you know
putting on the the mask of of faith or
you know drinking from the water bottle
of love or something like that
these refer to complex realities
within human beings that then we try to
conceptualize and we name
but we have to be very attentive to in
our our analyses
uh ask ida when's the next reading
good question i haven't put any new
readings on the calendar
i probably
should look at that before classes began
it was pretty easy for me to do
thursday readings let me see what my
thursdays look like i can probably keep
doing these thursday readings
uh at the same time um because i have
stuff up until noon
noon my time whatever time it is uh
uh where you are
um
like for mark it's evening because it's
um he's in south africa
so i'll probably i'll keep doing these
weekly readings if i get super busy i
may have to space them out a bit more
we're moving to the season of stoicism
and andy my my wife and i are organizing
stoicon itself as well as well as i'm
the editor of stoicism today so that
that keeps me pretty busy
um
but yeah we'll keep up with these i
didn't know whether i would get through
as it turns out i didn't uh all of um
brahir's presentation
i think probably
more than just bray here's thing is
gonna have to be broken up like jill
stones
the notion of christian philosophy
is that doable in a single session yeah
yeah because it's only it's only uh 12
pages
blondels uh does christian philosophy
exist as cr his philosophy we can do
that but his is there a christian
philosophy
is from page
150 to page 175
probably have to break that one up into
two
atn borns on a christian philosophy that
would be philosophical it's pretty short
um blondel's the problem of catholic
philosophy
the meeting of the society detude
philosophy well that's a long one and
that's got discussions with uh blondel
polyair
bergere
his responses to a bunch so that's gonna
have to be broken up into quite a few
and then the the later ones i think
these are all fairly
short and can be done
in a single session of readings
yeah that that that's doable and i'm not
going to read the bibliography that
would be mind-numbingly boring
moxie do you have any opinion on the
lgbtq
plus
irrelevant to what we're doing here
obviously i have opinions but
we're not going to discuss them here
mark smith looking forward to the
blondel reading uh still trying to get
my hands on a copy of blondel's axio
um yeah you know i'll tell a funny story
about blondel's ex you know
so that was his dissertation right his
his french dissertation because back
then you had to do a latin dissertation
which he did on leibniz's vinculum uh
the the chain connecting things and then
he wrote accion 1893
which almost didn't pass
and actually got him in trouble with the
french philosophical establishment
um
got him like sent out to the boonies
after they put him on ice for two years
didn't give him a job um
so accio in 1883 they printed out you
know the first edition and
like a print run of like maybe a
thousand or so
and they like sold like hotcakes they
were gone right you couldn't get your
hands on them
william james came to france and he was
like can i get a copy of this book that
everybody's talking about and people
like nope not giving you my copy he
wrote to blondel and he said hey man uh
you got any extra copies
and blondel sent him a copy and said i'm
gonna need this back when you're done
with it
afterwards
james found out that that was blondel's
only existing copy and that blondel
was willing to like you know what it's
like when you lend books oftentimes you
don't get them back you know and the
fact that somebody's a famous
philosopher doesn't make it any more
likely they're going to return your
books
so
james afterwards returns the book and
blondel's like
i'm glad you returned it because uh i
don't have any other copies left
so
it sometimes can be a hard book to get
your hands on so on that we'll we'll
leave off that that's a great story
uh with two great thinkers uh mark says
lending books is true charity
that's that's a that's a great point all
right so i will see you all hopefully
for another reading next week and i'll
put it in the calendar um
and thanks for hanging in there this is
kind of a long slog with with right here
although his he is a good stylist i will
say so all right i'll see you later